everybody says there is no such thing as
a universal solution
and i actually think that's
fundamentally wrong and because we don't
conceive of universal solutions we
wander
around as if we don't know what to do
but there's all sorts of things
that are fundamentally correct no matter
where you are and i'm going to give you
a list
first is you need to understand and
preserve
natural ecology's history and culture
many places actually in their rush to
development
overlook all of that the urban growth
boundary is the
one dimension of this particular
principle that you need to preserve
what's most valuable in a place that's a
universal principle
and you can actually assign specific
actions to making it
real you can map where all the
ecological
and endangered species are you can
isolate
buildings and historic places second is
mixed use
there's no great city that isn't mixed
use this is a universal
principle what does mixed use mean
it means that instead of zoning by use
here's one kind of housing here there's
a shopping center here
there's an office park here and they
don't overlap
they don't combine they're isolated and
separate
mixed use literally puts things side by
side
say within a city block or even
vertically
so housing over shops but mixed use also
has a more profound
meaning that you don't build one kind of
housing for one income group
in one place you mix different housing
opportunities together
so there's a range of people all
interacting
in their common area you know mixed use
also means
bring nature into the environment rather
than putting it
in a separate category somewhere else
that's what people desire that's what
people love and it's actually the most
robust socially because it involves the
kinds of interaction
that makes society civil connections
the scale of development there are
absolutes there the human body describes
a human scale
and connections really have to be framed
there that's another
universal principle public space
architects focus on buildings objects
you've got to think about the space
between the buildings that's where
life happens and that's where the life
of a culture in a city happen
and you can actually talk about what
scale
the neighborhood parks are how frequent
they should be
and what kind of regional and cultural
facilities need to happen at what scale
these are all knowable principles
no great place is without walking and
biking
and there are some very simple rules
about that
you know how wide should a bike lane be
we know it's the same here as it is
anywhere else in the world we can
actually put it down and say this is a
universal
best practice we need to enhance
transit certainly we've had an explosion
of all sorts of local
mobility forms and that's all very
exciting
you need to make space in our right of
ways for all of that
and we need to focus we need to use
those modes
as the armature of growth we need to
stop using freeways
as the framework of our city and we have
to start
making walkable streets and transit
networks
the the armature around which we grow
the city so these are all things we know
and we can actually quantify and we can
quantify
the benefits and it doesn't hurt to have
a checklist